we got an important question this hour
it's a question actually kind of a
timeless question about redevelopment
projects in densely populated
neighborhoods
what is lost when the government
acquires personal property in the name
of innovation and infrastructure and who
pays that price a debate is underway in
houston where a controversial freeway
widening project is threatening to
disrupt the lives of thousands of people
most of them from communities of color
ben tracy traveled to texas to talk with
people on both sides of this debate and
he met one local pastor forced to find a
new home for his church
at greater mount olive baptist church in
houston
pastor joseph johnson has led his flock
for 25 years
he's a man of deep faith but these days
so eventually this freeway is going to
come over here and take over the church
he's finding it very hard to love his
neighbor
from the picture that they show us they
tell us we are sitting in lane number
seven
lane number seven we are sitting in lane
number seven mount olive shares this
corner with houston's interstate 610
the freeway is about to be widened and
mount olive is in the way i feel like
all the hard work that we did and
everything we were striving for
it was being taken away from us and then
i think about you know all this going to
be destroyed and he knows what that
feels like
when hurricane ike battered houston back
in 2008 a falling tree destroyed mount
olive you see a lot of hard work
a lot of hard work pastor johnson
rebuilt it with his own two hands
proudly opening the doors to this new
church just six years ago what is it
going to be like to walk out those doors
for the last time very difficult when i
have to stand back
and watch them come here come here with
those
big machines
and how they're going to start biting
into this building
when it took us years to build it here
it only going to take them a couple days
to destroy it
houston
does have a problem a booming population
is making traffic terrible but the
massive 9 billion dollar plan to widen
24 miles of interstate is hitting mostly
black and hispanic neighborhoods hard
about one thousand homes and apartments
along with 344 businesses two schools
and five churches are expected to be
knocked down
including some in historic independence
heights the first texas city
incorporated by african americans back
in the early 1900s sometimes i feel like
we're easy prey tanya dubose took us for
a walk through independence heights
she's trying to protect it not only from
the freeway but also from gentrification
which is forcing out long time residents
nobody cares about the people who are
being displaced here
and where they go
dubose then brought us back to the
freeway to show us what was lost here a
long time ago so this is where your
great grandfather's house used to be
yeah right here on this
this intersection where this exit is
when the interstate was first built back
in 1959
dubose's great grandfather was forced
from his home that's a home that i could
have moved into what's being lost here
is generational wealth and what do you
say to those folks who say somebody has
to sacrifice for the greater good and
this is where the road needs to be i'm
going to try to be nice here but how
about it doing it in your backyard
because the people here have been to
sacrifice for so long the federal
government has put most of the houston
project on hold while it investigates
possible civil rights and environmental
violations you're creating this
saturated area with high levels of
pollution
texas southern university professor
robert bullard has led the environmental
justice movement for decades most of
these roads will be four six even eight
lane expressways when the u.s interstate
highway system was built in the 1950s
and 60s more than a million people were
forced from their homes and many black
neighborhoods bulldozed this pattern is
a national pattern at what point do you
stop repeating and reproducing this
inequality the same communities that are
out there now in northeast houston
they're still fighting for justice
we need to work together because doing
nothing
is not the solution
raquel lewis is with the texas
department of transportation she says
it's working with impacted communities
and offering buyouts sometimes over
market value to anyone displaced by the
freeway project do you acknowledge the
impact that this has on these
communities and the sacrifice these
people are being asked to make
absolutely we do or i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that it's a perfect
project there's plenty of opportunity
for us to evolve and make modifications
and take into consideration how do we
make it better
pastor johnson took the state's buy out
but with skyrocketing building costs
he's worried it's not enough to build a
new church on this nearby land when
mount olive is demolished my faith is
god is going to bring us through this
like they will say one way or another
god is going to bring us through it for
now the road ahead is full of
uncertainty for cbs morning's i'm ben
tracy in houston
wow that last point about the pastor
looking and thinking i may have gotten
all this money but i can't even afford
to potentially rebuild that becomes part
of the problem that was also referenced
about generational wealth yeah exactly i
was told as a young man if you want to
invest in something buy land because
that's something that they don't make
anymore but that's what the idea that
that same land is not snatched from you
in order for a city to build more lands
and it's you know they're going to pay
market value maybe a little bit above
but if you don't get to choose the time
of your sale right you don't have a lot
of choice at all right that's